[MUSIC]
Hello and welcome, good morning, good day.
Good evening, wherever in the world
you are joining us from today.
I am so thrilled that you are here.
My name is Wil, let us know where
you are tuning in from, and
then three words that would describe you.
We will be making use of these
three words in a little bit.
So even if you aren't to come up with
ones that fit right at this moment,
we have a little bit more
time to workshop those.
I'll go ahead and get us started.
I want to make sure that we're able
to maximize the time we have today.
So, to set the roadmap for
what we're going to do,
I have an exercise that
we're going to start.
We already started to precede it with
the three words that describe you.
We'll do a little bit more with that but
with that exercise,
that is going to be a running theme that
we're going to continue to unpack today.
Because my goal is to really help all
of you better understand the holistic
review process that we
use here at Stanford GSB.
There's a lot of kind of myth and
rumor, and
it can often feel like
the evaluation process.
And the admissions process is a black box,
but it doesn't have to be that way.
So my goal today is to help you
understand more about that process so
that today can be the foundation for
Application Week.
Each of our events this week
are geared towards helping you
understand with a bit more detail.
Both of the parts of the application
as well as tips, strategies,
frameworks that you can use and apply.
So really help put your best
foot forward in this process.
Maybe you're not thinking about Stanford,
ultimately,
maybe business school
doesn't end up being for you.
My hope is that also through some of the
exercises that we're able to do together,
these are things not just
dependent on outcome.
But you're also going to find
value in that process and
these are ways to really think about,
what is it that you really want to do?
What's that next step you're
going to take in your life and
how might we be able to
assemble the tools, skill sets,
learnings that'll help you get there,
whether it's business school.
Hopefully it's the GSB, but anywhere
in your life that those come from,
how can we get from point A to point
B in a way that's right for you?
So, coming back to today's events,
a holistic review primer just
to get a sense of what is it?
What is it not?
Because oftentimes it's
that what is it not space.
Where we can be the cleanest and
clearest and
really help kind of
illuminate the process.
From there, we'll go ahead and
talk about what it is we do look for and
where we find it.
And then what does that mean for you, and
I think that's where we really get
into the spirit of this week's events.
How can you think about
the application pieces and
the application process in a way
that you can understand, hey,
maybe these are the details I
should be sharing about myself.
I didn't know reflection kind
of in this realm was okay, or
I just have a question about
transcripts or testing.
We have events for that as well, but
the more questions that we're able to
initiate, the more answers and the greater
clarity we're going to be able to provide.
We'll have about 50 minutes
together on today's live session.
For those of you who might be watching
this on replay, I'll give cues for,
let's go ahead and pause here and
then give yourself some time
to go through this exercise.
And then jump back on and to continue
to see how we unpack, process, and
connect the dots between the different
things we're doing and the MBA,
GSB application process.
All right, let's get going.
So as a preface, there is a ton
of information out there and
I think even that is an understatement.
There's a lot of advice,
some of it is great advice, some of it,
otherwise, but take anything
you hear with a grain of salt.
Including the things that I'm going to
be sharing with you today and
that our staff will be sharing with
you over the course of the week.
We can speak truth about the application
process and how we interpret and evaluate.
And that's our goal this week
to really lift that curtain.
In terms of what you should
do as an individual, however,
part of the beauty of this process is
there is no right way or wrong way.
It's really how are we able to
give you the power to understand,
what is it that you want?
How are we going to get there?
What are the elements of your journey and
your story that you are going to let
shine and sing through this process?
We want to give you the power and
that looks different for each and
every one of you.
Part of this is understanding who you are,
how you show up in spaces,
and as you think even
beyond the MBA experience,
what does that mean for
how you navigate through life?
This is just the one step on
an ongoing journey of your life,
so take anything with a grain of salt.
This is no rulebook, but rather, maybe an
orientation guide to some different things
to help you understand where you kick
start that process if you ever get stuck.
So hopefully, take that come in fresh
eyes on willingness to try new things,
and then we'll go down some
really interesting tasks.
All right, so it all starts with you and
this is not an understatement,
this is going to be the theme that
comes up throughout the week.
So we are actually going to start
application week by talking about you.
So, grab a piece of paper, maybe you're
just jotting things down on your tablet,
maybe you're opening up a window, but I'm
going to give you a little bit of time.
So let's start off,
make a short list about yourself.
I say 10 things here but
definitely feel free to do more.
Here are some examples of things
you might be writing about.
Let's start with those three words.
Sometimes being able to crystallize and
distill those elements of who you are and
the things that resonate for you can
be a great starting point to unpack and
learn more about yourself, which is
what the MBA is all about as well.
Yes, it's about building some of
those core business fundamentals,
the skill sets that you're going to
need to be able to lead a group or
organization in any setting.
And at Stanford, there's that extra piece,
right, that leadership development,
that investment in you to help you
understand, why should someone follow you.
To start that conversation,
you need to begin at least, hopefully,
with at least some semblance or
understanding of who you are.
So let's go ahead and
start that process together.
What are some things you do for fun?
What are things that excite you?
Maybe when you pick up a book,
these are the types of things that
keep you turning those pages.
When you see a show on TV, or
maybe you're watching movie,
you're like,
let me go learn more about that.
And then you go up, you do a little bit
of Internet searching to learn more.
What are those things?
Maybe it's a topic you can talk
about at length with your friends.
So anything and
everything is fair game here.
I'll give you a little bit
more time to write through.
So if you aren't able to make
it through all ten, no worries.
As long as you get a couple of
these bullet points going for
our extended use [LAUGH] of this list,
you're headed in the right spot.
So as example, I did this along with you.
So [LAUGH] here's my cheat sheet posted
with some of the things about myself.
So my few words are enthusiastic,
supportive, and bald.
So [LAUGH] these might be a little
obvious but sometimes it's
those obvious things that really impact
the way that you move through space.
So don't feel like everything has to be
a deep kind of revelation about yourself.
If it is great, but sometimes it's those
immediate elements of who you are that can
often lead to some of the most
interesting insights about who you are.
I guarded for fun, I find it
really relaxing and I love nature.
A skill that I've worked on which is,
I guess,
kind of perfect for
the work I do is reading applications and
really trying to understand who you are as
applicants and really honor the effort and
all of the detail that you're
investing into this process.
I care a lot about diversity,
equity, inclusion and belonging,
both as you think about it in the US
setting but also internationally.
How do we celebrate diversity within and
among diversity?
How do we bring those
perspectives together so
that we can learn from each other?
And then how can we create spaces where
people feel comfortable letting people
know they're different?
Sometimes that can be the hardest thing.
And if we're able to create
these inclusive spaces when
we're feel comfortable and
safe and able to voice these,
those are the moments that can lead
to some of the greatest growth and
support and relationship
building with those around you.
And so that is really important to me.
And I can talk about fish.
This [LAUGH] May seem a little facetious,
but what I want you to do next is
continue adding things throughout, and
we are actually going to start talking
about the holistic review process.
More to come on that list,
so keep adding to it.
But what is it?
This is going to be the heart of
the conversation throughout this week.
And it's important to
understand our process and
the review process specifically so
that you can understand the utility and
purpose of each of the sections.
Once you're better able to understand that
and how we use them, that will hopefully
help you understand, okay, what types
of information can I be sharing?
How should I share it?
And given the whole range of things I
could be talking about, how can I distill
them into those word counts, those limits,
or as I think about it, the frameworks and
canvases that are provided for
you to paint and kind of color within.
So, definition of holistic as a
philosophy, and I'm going to go ahead and
read this because I think this is a really
beautiful encapsulation of our philosophy
for reading applications as well and
the evaluation process here at the GSB.
So, holistic philosophy, characterized
by comprehension of the parts of
something as intimately interconnected and
explicable only by reference to the whole.
So, elements depend on each other for
us to understand the greater
picture of who you are and
one thing as extra dimension and
visibility into who you are, what you do,
how do you show up in spaces?
Definition to credit here to where
it's coming from Oxford languages,
[LAUGH] thank you.
But what does this mean for you?
In our evaluation process,
what I want you to take a look at
are some of the key takeaways.
As we're reading applications that
wholeness is really important,
so we do not use formulas,
we don't use equations,
there's not an algorithm that we use to
make admissions decisions at the GSB.
This might be very different from
admissions processes elsewhere and
especially international settings
where sometimes that test is
really a precursor or the determinant
of what happens or where you go next.
That's not so at the GSB.
So what we're looking at is so
much bigger than that,
we're going to be unpacking
that throughout today.
There are no benchmarks, no cutoffs or
quotas as part of the evaluation process.
So, oftentimes I hear well, how many
people do you take from my industry or
I hear you only take two people
from my country every year.
And they come from x and
y industries, one from each.
And that is actually the furthest
[LAUGH] From what our process does.
We are taking a look at you as
an individual where no one part of
the application matters more than
the other because each adds to that
whole holistic view of who you
are where context really does matter.
So maybe it is elements of your industry
that helps determine how might some
of those leadership or accomplishments
that you do in your everyday work?
How do those show up?
That looks different in
consulting setting than
it might in an entrepreneurial setting.
But, just because they
show up differently,
doesn't mean one is necessarily really
more or less important or valuable or
impactful than the other,
it's just the context that changes.
That can also be said for those of you
who might be applying early, right?
So maybe you are currently in college or
an early career professional,
we understand that, and that is
a built into the application process.
We don't expect you to have had
necessarily leadership roles necessarily.
We don't expect you to have anything
that someone who've been working 10,
11,12 years might have under their
resume or under their belts,
you have different worlds,
we are looking at you within yours.
For those of you who might be on that
more exterior side of the spectrum,
it's not just what you did but,
what did you do given that time?
How did you maximize the resources and
opportunities that were provided for you?
Who are you because of that?
And what are some of the footprints
that you left behind, right?
Those footprints again are going to look
different depending on where you are,
what you did and
even what you might hope to do next?
Those are the key takeaways I
want you to take from here.
We are really looking through our entire
application to get the best sense
of who you are, who you might show up as
in our classrooms and in our community.
So what do we look for?
This is where we're going to,
again, come back to you.
I think you are going to be
the best illustration for
the message that we're
trying to get across today.
So, go ahead and bring back that list.
And to give a little preview
of what I want you to do next,
we are going to talk about three things,
intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential and
personal qualities and contributions.
These are both a mouthful and
can be a lot to write down, so
go feel free to [LAUGH] Use some
acronyms here, Stanford and
Stanford as a whole is a very
acronym friendly place.
So if I refer to these as IV,
DLP, and PQ or PQ and
C, these are the things that
I'm going to be referring to,
please feel free to use these that
the shorthand as part of this exercise.
If you are writing on a Word document or
some other space where you might be
a little bit more limited in the ways you
are using kind of text boxes or whatever.
Go ahead and you were just going to put
IV next to the thing that strikes you
as encapsulating what in electrical
vitality looks like for you.
So for me that I can talk about fish teas,
I actually have a degree in marine
biology, there is something about nature
and ecosystems and the way species
interact with each other that really
speaks to me and just fascinates me.
And I really love fish for
multiple reasons that we're
not going to get into today.
Except to say that both at
a scientific intellectual level as
well as elements of family and
memories and personal growth and
history, these are all things
that makes sense to me.
And so for you,
as I talk about the descriptions for
each one of those categories, feel free to
draw that line to make that connection.
Or add that IV, DLP notation next to
it in whatever format works best for
you in the here and now.
Okay, so for those of you who are going
to be watching this later on,
I'm going to give a description.
Feel free to pause after each
description to give yourself time
to draw some of these lines and
connections.
So, let's get started.
Again, you can use as many bullet points
as many times as you want, no limits here.
This is all about you.
So I'm going to clear my stuff.
We don't need that cluttering the space.
Let's focus on our criteria.
So if you haven't done so already,
I highly recommend that you go to our
evaluation criteria section of
the GSB MBA admissions website.
There's some really great language
here on all three of these topics.
For intellectual vitality, there are some
rhetorical questions to help you think
about what are some of the different
ways this comes to life from you.
In terms of demonstrated
leadership potential,
they're actually examples of what are some
of the types of leadership competencies
that you might be exhibiting
in your life as well.
So definitely jump on that website,
bookmark it, I find it incredibly useful.
Both for this process, but also to think
about, hey, how do I get things done?
What are things that are important to me?
How does this show up in my mind?
So intellectual vitality,
I like to think of this as what is
your relationship with knowledge.
It's so much more than a test score or
a GPA, right?
Those are indicators of how you performed
on a test or how you did in a classroom.
But you are so much more than that.
What are the things that make your
eyes light up when you hear a topic?
What are the things that you
can talk about at length?
And thinking about the type of place
Business School is, thinking about
the collaborative environment at the GSB
and how you're learning as much from
your classmates, professors, speakers,
as much as they are from you.
How do you also share that
knowledge with others?
Everybody takes a different approach,
and that's cool.
There is something about different ways of
learning and understanding that when they
come together, they can help push you
out of kind of where you might have been
before, to really take a look at issues
and problems from new perspectives.
And that's how we're going to define and
identify the solutions of the future.
So how are you going to
bring that mindset,
that learning growth element to the table?
Where are those spaces
that your mind sings?
Demonstrated leadership potential DLP,
think about this as two parts.
Demonstrated leadership and
leadership potential.
So both go hand in hand,
but are slightly nuanced.
So demonstrated leadership can be thought
about as what are things you have done.
And context matters here, for those of
you who might be applying as a deferred
candidate, some of this might
be happening in college.
For those of you who might be working and
in the professional world,
some of that leadership might
have been on a project.
It might have been in
an organization team level.
Leadership can also be demonstrated
on an individual or one on one level.
So think very broadly about this,
and it's not just what you've done,
but how have you done it.
What are some of those skill
sets that you've applied?
What are some of those aha moments,
or how did you drive results?
Those are those pieces that are just
as important to us in this process as
the accomplishments.
Part of the application is to understand
from past behavior, how was this
individual, what are some of the ways that
they might behave again in the future?
This is a great indicator.
So unpacking and disassembling
the process behind the output is going to
be a very important tool for
you throughout this process.
And it's, I think something that is
going to be incredibly useful as
you're learning and going through
this kind of leadership development
journey throughout Business School and
beyond.
What is that internal dialogue
that you can have here?
So personal qualities and
contributions, who are you?
What are the things from your lived
experience that you're going to be able to
contribute?
What are some of those perspectives that
you're going to be bringing to the GSB
both in the classroom and community?
Diversity broadly defined falls under
this, because different lived experiences
will come in with different thoughts and
ideas about things.
At the GSB, one of our priorities
is how do we create and
cultivate spaces where these differences
of opinions are encouraged and
supported so that they come up, so
that we can have these learnings.
I know this is something that is important
as we continue to move into the future.
Where so many of our problems are going to
require folks coming together from across
so many different ranges of viewpoints,
backgrounds, different priority sets.
How do we have constructive conversation
to figure out a possible path forward?
What is your perspective?
How do you bring it to the table?
How are we using that as an opportunity
for both of those around you?
Who are you?
So, with each one of those, go ahead and
take a moment, jump on your list.
We're going to bring that list back up,
build those connections.
I did some of that right here.
I use three different colors just
to make some of the lines easier.
So intellectual vitality,
there's also this element of
biology that fascinates me.
What are some of the geographic
distributions of native plants and
how have those evolved over time
as human geography has brought
crops with them to different
parts of the world?
And then how have those ingredients
been used in those recipes, and
what does that mean for culture there?
I find all of that stuff fascinating,
I love the application process.
I think about it a lot,
[LAUGH] more than I probably should.
And it's something that
at a leadership level,
I appreciate the opportunity
to help my team learn, grow.
And how can we facilitate
conversations about things like bias,
about diversity, about lived experience?
And how does that factor into
the application in the real process?
So leadership kind of both on
that practical tactical way and
also in that thought leadership
within our department.
And then personal qualities and
contributions.
A lot of different ways this can go here,
but
in terms of caring about inclusion and
belonging, it's really important for
me that my teammates feel like they
can show up, come as they are.
And how can we unlock our greatest
potential and effectiveness?
By understanding and recognize,
and really seeing each other.
And that's kind of one of those things
I bring to the table for my team.
So if you are watching, go ahead and
pause right now, draw some of these lines.
Take a moment because sometimes the lines
aren't always as clearly defined as you
think, you might find some
very interesting pieces here.
So I talked a little bit
about that inclusion element.
But you'll see, not everything
here is super clearly defined.
I don't know where baldness comes
into play for intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential, or
personal qualities right from the get go.
But I thought it was important enough
to include as one of my three words.
So take some time to unpack that.
As I think about, okay,
what does this mean?
Oftentimes the way the world perceives
you impacts the way that you were treated
over time that results in me understanding
like I do need to moderate and
modulate how I show up
depending on where I am.
Maybe it's clothes, maybe it's the words
I use, maybe it's the body language.
So how do I think about all of
these different dialects of code
switching in a way that helps
make sure that this and
this doesn't overly impact or
bias the way folks treat me, right.
That's something I realized that
I do on a subconscious level but
and that comes from, this.
So if even for things that might seem
facetious, even for things that might seem
surface level or really obvious,
I encourage you to take a step back and
understand and really draw some of
those connections for yourself.
Again, I'm talking a lot about
this internal dialogue about,
how do you show up in a space?
Sometimes that's metaphorical,
sometimes it's actual and
through the MBA application process.
And through the GSB application process,
particularly we invite you to go on that
kind of personal kind of development and
reflection journey.
So, already getting to some of that with
understanding your list who you are.
And how do these elements of our
evaluation criteria come to life for you?
These are going to be different for
everybody out there, you are the only
person who really knows that for you,
that baldness comes across as intellectual
vitality and not demonstrated
leadership potential or vice versa.
Maybe you are part of an organization for
men or women, or
those who identify other as
something other than man or
woman to talk about baldness, right?
So there's different ways that you can
lead, or have intellectual vitality or
demonstrate some of these personal
qualities that only you can define.
So, where do we find these things?
In our application, there are going to
be eight different sections,
over the course of this week,
we are going to unpack a lot of these.
So tomorrow we have a panel with some of
my colleagues about testing transcripts in
academics, there's a session
on letters of reference,
one coming up towards the end of the week,
connecting the dots.
I'm really excited by, because that is
where we're going to go really deeply and
how do these different parts
of the application work
in concert with each other?
How can you think about them at
the tactical practical level in a way that
will help you understand okay?
Maybe this is a spot where I can
talk about this piece of myself, or
I didn't realize that was
important to include here.
Today, how you level
setting those foundations,
each one of our events this week
we'll dive in with much more detail.
Educational history,
including your transcripts,
what schools you have gone to kind of
what are some of those learnings and
things you've done on that
journey to where you are today?
Test scores,
just one part of the broader picture here,
personal activities and
awards, kind of who are you?
Kind of at that personal information
level, professional experience,
this includes your resume.
This works in concert with that employment
history section of the application.
And we'll talk a lot about
that relationship and
are connecting the dots
session later this week.
Letters of reference has been
a really hot topic in our
information sessions as a question
that comes up in the Q&A.
So we really wanted to give it the time
and space for us to go really go there and
talk about how both you can set yourself
up for success as an applicant.
And if you're watching as a recommender,
or if you're working with a recommender,
what are some things they can do as
well to help you shine in this process?
The essays and
optional short response questions,
these are opportunities to
talk about in your voice.
What are the things that
are important to you?
And this is one of those places
where as you start to unpack and
really understand, here's that list
of ten things about myself or more.
Here is why it's meaningful for me,
here are some of those connections,
that's where you start to really step out
of whatever boxes might be checked to
really add that slowness and dimension and
uniqueness to who you are and
what you bring to the table.
And then there is an interview as
part of our application process,
each one of our admitted students
will go through an interview.
These are behavioral based
mostly done by our alumni and
we'll talk a lot about interviews.
How do you share your story both
starting it in the written form and
verbally as in an interview in our
sharing the story seriously this week.
So, but getting beyond just sections,
how do they work together
to help us understand you?
So coming back to that definition
of holistic just as a reminder,
we are looking at each one of
these sections, to understand and
get a different window and
angle to who you are, right.
We're trying to build the fullest picture
is possible, notice that there's gaps
in this image, there are pieces
that we may never know fully.
To get that best picture,
how do we close some of these gaps?
How do we make sure that the details
that you're including in each one of
these little segments provides
the most vivid picture possible?
So that we understand, yes,
this is your shoulder and
not of a blog or a chair.
But we're really starting to see okay,
this is the piece that fits in with
the whole so that we can go through
your that assessment kind of giving you
that full dude on like diligence and
justice to who you are, okay?
Bring him back that list you
thought we were done with it,
we're going to do one more thing
with it before we go to Q&A.
So, thinking about those three things,
intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership potential
personal qualities and contribution.
We are going to draw lines through
your list one more time, but
we're going to take it a step further,
so, tell me about a time when,
so, I talked a little bit
about diversity inclusion.
So what this could look like is this
is where you get into that show,
don't tell kind of frame of mind.
I care about something or for
many of you who were talking about passion
How does that show up for you, right?
How can we give these pieces some meat on
the bones so that when we're going into
the application, there's evidence,
this is an evidence driven process.
So while there is no formula
there is no cut offs there
no pre kind of preconceived
notion of who are admitted
students are and
it's an evidence based process.
So as we're trying to build that,
compelling argument for
why you should be joining our class,
it's those evidence pieces that
are going to be the most helpful.
So drawing the lines between, hey,
here are some descriptors, some high-level
things about who I am, here's evidence for
that, here's that quote-unquote proof.
And so one of the ways that I care
about inclusion and belonging and
that it showed up as kind of
something that I did in my life was
an action that I've taken
to move something forward.
Is that in this past year as
the United States really grappled with
who we are as a nation also thinking about
interracial kind of dynamics and systems.
That allows some communities to thrive,
well forces others to struggle beyond
what could or should be happening.
The University at Stanford University
hosted a series of events
called brave spaces.
I was a facilitator for these
conversations, intentional spaces for
us to talk about race.
Difference, justice.
What does that mean?
How have we experienced it as individuals?
And how can we bring this conversation
kind of to the forefront of what we do,
such that the university can be a more
inclusive space where we can really
work and operate to our fullest potential?
And so, do this exercise,
come up with that,
these lists of things about
who you are and sometimes,
you might have a stroke of
inspiration somewhere, bring that in.
If you're thinking, hey,
is this important for the application,
let's take a look at
the criteria that Stanford uses.
How might this connect?
What's an example for
how this came out in the real world?
And then that could be one way
that you start to identify, okay,
here are some things that I really want to
make sure come out in my application.
Here are some of those landmarks
that I want to provide,
so that while I'm navigating this as
an applicant, whoever is reading this can
also navigate the course and journey of
my life in a way that they are seeing
the things that have really shaped who
I am and how I'm going to show up.
So, tips.
We are getting close, I want to make
sure we get through these tips and so
that I can jump into that Q&A box.
If you have questions,
go ahead and add them here.
We also have an up voting feature.
So go ahead if there is a question that
you find really resonates for you,
click that thumbs up button, it's going to
help elevate that question to the top.
I'm going to do my best to answer as many
questions as I can with our final ten
minutes together.
For some of them, I might be refer you to
some other events throughout this week,
and others,
I'm really going to try and unpack it.
Some of this philosophical and background
understanding level to help provide
that understanding and process based
approach, as opposed to just the output.
One of my colleagues talked about this and
talked about how are we coaching you
to self coach through this process?
How can we give you the tools and
knowledge and tool kits, so
that you can be your best self
advocate through this journey?
So, let's get to those tips.
We're going to do a little bit
unpacking and then get to the Q&A.
So first, own your journey.
No two people came to the GSB
following the same trajectory.
Everybody does think a little bit
differently, know yours, celebrate yours.
You'd be surprised at how often
the things that you do every day,
probably without even thinking about it,
are some of the most fascinating
things to us, on the admissions side.
The things like,
how do you operate within a team?
Maybe it's the way that you interact
with the people around you.
You don't often think twice about it,
it doesn't always come up with an award,
or achievement, or
something that defines it.
But that is a doublesome ways to lead,
right?
So really take that step back,
kind of release whatever notions you
might have heard about what quote
unquote leadership looks like,
release whatever ideas you have
about what admissions wants to hear,
and take control of your story.
This is me, this is what I want to tell
the MBA admissions office about myself.
As you take control of this journey,
no one can tell you how or
what you should be saying, right?
People can give input or
folks can provide some coaching, but
ultimately, you are the expert in you.
So let that come to the forefront and
really anchor on the things
that matter to you.
One of the things that I often see,
which is often a missed opportunity,
I would say is, it can be really
tempting to look at different models.
Here's the thing that got me in or
this is what you're supposed to
do XYZ to get into Stanford.
Because each one of you is different,
because each one of you brings
a different lived experience and
skill set of competencies for leadership,
action, whatever lenses you bring,
that might have worked for someone.
And if you try to mold yourself to
that sometimes the things that make
you the most effective, or the elements
about you that can really be the most
impactful in a business school
application or journey,
you might lose those because
you're trying to be someone else.
We're celebrating you.
Your classmates are going to be
learning from you, so own this journey.
Find value in the process and
not just the outcome.
And we're going to go
a little bit better here.
I mean this both in terms of
the outcome of the application process,
yes, admission would be great,
and the reality is,
that is not going to be the outcome for
everyone.
That said, this process going through
the exercise of understanding
what matters to you, these are things
that can help guide you as you come
to different decision points in your life.
Maybe you have two jobs that
you might be considering.
How do you choose which one?
Maybe it's by going with
what matters to you.
Maybe there's an ethical
dilemma that you're facing.
Let's go back to these core mission
pieces and values that you hold to
help guide you through some of
these kind of points in life.
So even beyond the application outcome,
there is still value behind going
through it and really taking the moment to
process and allow yourself to go there.
Think about this beyond just the pure
functionality of getting in, but rather,
maybe even think about it as a coaching
exercise that you are guiding yourself
through.
As for the things in your application,
you can also think about this as not
just the outcome, but how did you do it?
Coming back to that DLP
demonstrated leadership potential.
What did you do and how?
What was the setting around it?
Who else was involved?
What happened next?
Tell me more.
That is one of my favorite questions kind
of talking to folks that tell me more, and
so I really encourage you to take a moment
to remember, reflect, process, connect.
So remember the things that happened,
things that you're proud of,
reflect on the situation around it.
I mentioned some instances that could or
some elements that could be handy, but
also reflect on how you were
feeling in those moments.
What were you challenged by?
What were you energized by process?
Take a moment and think about how
these things connect to each other.
In all actuality, I probably should
have ordered it as remember, reflect,
connect process, but I have to, [LAUGH]
I admit and in full disclosure here,
remember reflect, process,
connect is so much easier to remember.
But we can say those processing
connect pieces built together connect
the dots, right?
Because of this, that happened.
I was inspired by, XYZ.
See how these elements
connect to who you are today.
I learned this, I applied it there.
And that process piece take time to
process how all of these different
dots connect.
There might be dots that
you never realized existed.
Maybe it's through that
exercise we did today.
Maybe you didn't know that you
really did engage with baldness at
an intellectual level.
Give yourself time to unpack,
celebrate, and explore through this.
And remember, through all of it,
it all begins with you.
Okay, so
that is what I have prepared right now.
So I'm going to jump into our Q&A box.
Before we do that, I really want to
encourage everybody here to continue your
journey at MyStanford.mba.
And with some short questions, we're able
to create a dashboard that will help,
Consolidate some of the events that
may be of most interest to you.
There is also an application tracker
to help keep you kind of up to date on
where you are and
get you go into that finish line.
I really encourage you,
if you aren't sure whether or
not you should apply now or
in the future, take a moment and think.
What is it that you want to do?
How can Stanford get you there?
If you're thinking we can,
I encourage you, go ahead,
do this process, take these moments
to really celebrate your journey.
Because tomorrow can be
a very beautiful thing and
I want to make sure that you give yourself
every opportunity to realize that.
So let me go ahead,
we are going to jump into that Q&A box.
So I'm going to stop sharing for
a moment and here we go.
So here's a question from Anna.
A number of you have also kind
of bumped this question up.
So Anna imagines that the GSB like
other business schools tries to admit
a diverse class.
How does that affect how they try to
balance students from different countries,
industries, etc.
So great question here.
I think ultimately,
the one number that we're trying
to target is bringing in a class.
So for
us that is still 20-ish year to year.
And even less if Lexis depending
on the circumstances, right?
But rather than focusing on that number or
is there some breakdown that we're
going towards, we're really
looking at you as an individual.
One of the kind of amazing things that
I really appreciate about the holistic
review process is that we don't think
about you as someone from x place,
but how does being from x place shape
the perspective that you bring?
And I think if you allow
yourself to take a step and
look at it from that perspective,
you're going to have a lot more
agency in demonstrating to us
that perspective that enhances
dialogue to the classroom or
spark conversations in the community.
This might sound like a little bit
of a tangent of an answer, but
something that we talked about, something
that Dean Moss has talked to me about and
we've had conversations about this is,
staying on your side of the net.
What does that mean, right?
If you think about a game like tennis or
volleyball,
you are in control of what's
happening on your side of the net.
What's happening and what the other
person decides to do, that's up to them.
So as we think about this application
process, my goal with this week is to
bring more light and visibility to what
are the pieces on your side of the net so
that you can understand,
okay, here are the steps.
I can take left, right, around.
And so not that I'm trying to
give a non-answer answer, but
at a practical sense, there's actually
a whole field called enrollment
management where this is
part of the consideration.
How are we bringing in as
diverse cohort as possible?
I think one of the lucky things for
us is that we do get a really broad
representation of extremely talented
individuals from around the world.
That said, sometimes I do
get the question, why are so
many people from the United States?
Or why are they so
many people from consulting?
Is that going to be a disadvantage for me?
Part of this is that those tend to
be some of our largest pipelines.
We can only admit the people who apply.
And so that is that other part of
encouraging you to take a step.
And if this is something
that you're thinking about,
don't count yourself out because you
don't immediately identify with what
it looks like on our class profile, right?
So couple different layers to that answer.
We really do care about the individual and
the talents that you bring.
We will never admit someone just
because of one thing, right?
And so regardless of where you come from,
hopefully you're able to share
all of these pieces of us.
So build that case for
saying this is a compelling individual.
Thank you for that question, Anna.
From Deshaun, talking about very
themes that are within the bounds
of including in the application.
Can we touch upon what applicants should
avoid creating their application?
This might be useful for internationals
who might not be very familiar with the US
admissions process and expectations.
Thank you, Deshaun, for this question.
This is at the heart of
what we are trying to do.
I would say there is very little that
is off limits for the application.
So there might be a topic that
might feel controversial.
There might be a event in your life
that might not seem immediately
business related, but it really is
important to how you view yourself.
When it comes to the GSB application,
and I can't speak to all
applications out there.
But when it comes to the GSB application,
think about it as what
you're writing about is almost less
important than the so what of it.
What are you trying to
convey about yourself?
Or who are you because of x, y, or z
things that you're trying to write about?
And so
as long as that topic is in good taste,
and here's maybe one guideline that
you might take home with you is,
if you step back, and
let's talk about the essays for a second.
If by the end of that essay, I know more
about that topic than I do about you,
or how you engage with a topic,
how that shapes your perspective,
what you've done with it.
If I knew more about that topic than you,
some element of you,
that might be the moment to step back and
do a little bit of assessment and
shift kind of your angle on that.
So ultimately very little is off
the rails here [LAUGH] in this process,
which is both empowering and
a little bit intimidating,
not everything has to deal with business.
Again, thinking about how the individual
and what you bring to the table is so
much more than kind of the class
that you might be taking.
You are so much more than a test score or
transcript,
how can we recognize and celebrate that?
So that's a very high level answer.
Through this week,
we're actually going to dig into all
of these elements very specifically.
And I'm really looking forward to
our panels because I'm excited for
the conversations to come.
Okay, all right.
Question here and
this is more tactical practical.
When does it matter?
Round one, round two,
no major difference here.
And we'll also be talking about some
of that tactical practical with
the connecting of the dots.
I have time for one more question.
We're going to stick
to this philosophical.
How do we understand
the process to set up and
tee up the different
events we have this week?
And here's one from Cecilia.
Is there an ideal balance or
ratio of these aspects?
So I'm assuming intellectual vitality,
demonstrated leadership,
potential, personal qualities,
and contributions.
Would having too much or
not enough in one area be particularly
detrimental to an application?
And I can say wholeheartedly
the answer is no.
You don't have to have everything, right?
Each one of you,
think about the leaders and
people in your life that you look up to or
find really effective.
Everyone uses a different balance and
that's awesome.
As you're thinking about your balance,
right,
that's where we're starting to unpack.
Okay, so in this list of things,
what do you do?
How do you do them?
Okay, here's the balance of ivory and
fully recognize and celebrate that.
Not every leader, Dean Moss,
her research background is
actually in leadership assessment.
So if you're curious to learn more and
wants to learn more,
join us this Friday for
office hours with Dean Moss.
And she talks about many different
types of leadership competencies.
Not every leader will express all of them.
And starting this application process,
not everybody needs to express everything.
Some people are very spiky and really
excel in certain areas and that's awesome.
Other folks are a little bit more
balanced and do very things, and
that's awesome as well.
So regardless of your journey,
there is no preset kind of
balance that we're looking for.
Again, there's no formula,
no equation to our process.
We're really looking at you
kind of in the fullness of you.
So thank you again for joining us.
I want to be respectful
of everybody's time.
This is just the beginning
of our conversation.
We set the groundwork and started
an exercise that you can do to start
creating these stories and
understandings of who you are.
So that over the course of the week,
we can continue to process, unpack,
and answer questions as many as you have.
In the meanwhile,
feel free to message our email inbox.
We have a team of folks
who are there to support.
Thank you so much for joining me on this
very first event in application week,
navigating the application, this crash
course into the holistic review process.
I hope to see you across the events of
this week, and answer as many questions,
and really empower you to
take that step forward.
Remember, it all begins with you.
Thank you again y'all.
[MUSIC]